Neil this is a really ambitious book I
did a book on the Fed as you know but I
just did one narrow slice you tried to
do the whole world here tell me a little
bit about how this came to be look we've
been through a remarkable few years as
you know it started with what we call
the subprime crisis and of course has
turned into something much bigger and
much more global and and with much
broader effects than anything having to
do with with with mortgage securities in
the United States you know the deepest
and darkest days of the crisis in many
ways was the fall of two thousand eight
you wrote a wonderful book on that
andrew ross sorkin did a number of
people have I I wanted to try and
capture a slightly different story of
which that's only part which is this
this global story first of all of of how
what started is what we thought of as a
housing crisis in the United States and
a financial crisis became this this
global conflagration that has endangered
the you know 50 years of progress toward
European unity has worsened the British
economy for four years and years has had
really this global reach that that's
affected almost everybody on earth and I
wanted to tell that through the the
story that seemed most logical which is
the global central bankers who again and
again have been the ones who have tried
to corral this this this rapidly
spreading fire and try and contain it
whether it's in Europe with the with the
eurozone crisis that is in danger that
continent in the US with Ben Bernanke in
the Federal Reserve so I viewed a lot of
the books that were written in 2008-2009
that captured that that very intense
very remarkable crisis fighting stage as
a as a as a starting point and tried to
tried to capture how that story went
from there and the entire arc of this
last several years so how long did it
take you to do this well in some ways I
had kind of been building ideas in
building thread since i started covering
the Federal Reserve in 2007 I started on
the Fed beat about a week after after
what is actually the first scene in the
book the first introduction of the book
to thousands it's all my fault august
nine 2007 is where I start which is the
first day the european central bank
intervened to prop up the european
banking system week after that nobody i
wouldn't have put the two together at
the time but i started covering the Fed
so from that point on
had been gathering ideas and thread and
and and trying to think through what it
all meant I started seriously thinking
about a book in late 2010 and serious
reporting on the book into the start of
2011 now is the cover shows you did you
looked at a number of central bankers
not only Ben Bernanke but also Mervyn
King in the UK jean-claude trichet in
the European Central Bank hi ami the
Japanese and some of their successors
let's talk a little bit about these
three men who are on the cover of the
book so first Ben Bernanke what what do
you think people ought to know about Ben
Bernanke no Ben Bernanke it's a it's a
fascinating story he's I think in some
ways it's it's he's an accidental Fed
Chairman here he's one of the most
consequential central bankers in history
really and and no doubt one of the most
important leaders in the history of the
Federal Reserve and you know I think he
will he will get many more historical
treatments you and I I think both wrote
kind of first drafted that but I think
in many ways what's surprising is what
what an accidental series of incident
the Fed chairmanship he he hadn't served
in government he was a lifelong academic
in her government for the first time in
2002 thinking it would be a kind of
short-term thing he got to go back to
teaching it for exactly he got a call to
become a Federal Reserve governor one of
one of seven not not the chairman or
anything it was after nine eleven there
was the spirit of patriotism in the air
he had recently been passed over to
become the Provost of Princeton and for
all those reasons he said yes and came
for what he thought would be a short
tour in Washington now he proved to be
quite an effective public servants he
was a real thought leader on the on the
Federal Reserve as a governor President
Bush appointed him to his White House
chief economist job and any any
impressed a lot of people in the bush
administration but there's one more
level of coincidence here which is that
you know when it came time to replace
Alan Greenspan in 2005 george w bush was
not at his strongest point of his
presidency the iraq war was a mess his
popularity was low he'd had a failed
Supreme Court nomination and so Bernanke
was in many ways a safe choice if it
weren't for all of those things
combining it's it's very possible in
fact very likely someone else would have
been Federal Reserve Chairman when all
this happened right and and of course he
ironically was unfortunately been
of the Great Depression which seem like
a total irrelevant field of scholarship
but turned out to come in pretty handy
we go and I'm I'm told this didn't come
up in his interviews to be appointed
federal reserve chairman with with bush
or with those in the White House who
were kind of weighing this decision
Bernanke's scholarship and experience
with with crises with the with the Great
Depression as historian none of that
really came up at all which is it's a
coincidence really so how do you think
he's changed over the five or six years
that you've been watching you he's much
more savvy he's very much the he wasn't
is very much the academic he's he's
quiet he's cerebral he he seems to
derive very little joy if any from the
kind of the showmanship of Washington
whether it's you know flashy parties
whether it's you know the idea of going
but you know I'm choosing with
politicians I think none of that
appealed him one bit he's done it to the
degree he has to for his job but it's
not what appeals to him he would much
rather be at a Washington Nationals game
by himself or with his wife then then at
a Georgetown dinner party with with
politicians and you describe a little
bit in the book about how public
speaking wasn't really his strong suit
and he did something about that wasn't
yeah he had a still it's you still here
at once in a while he's a little quiver
in his voice when he's nervous you know
he worked with a with a speaking coach
early on to help present a more forceful
demeanor and in congressional hearings
and other public settings but what what
I mean when I say is more savvy I think
he's you know it early on he he seemed
to not understand the cynicism with
which you know a senator or a
congressman would would yell at him and
rail at him and a congressional hearing
and he would seem confused you know that
I thought I had a perfectly good
conversation with him at breakfast last
week I don't understand well it's kind
of the routine cynicism of Washington of
politics he's he's become a much more
savvy person about that so if you had to
look forward what grade do you think
history will give him I you know I think
he gets an a I you know there are plenty
of mistakes we can both point to that
have been made by Ben Bernanke in the US
Federal Reserve over the last several
years
I mean the Lehman Brothers failures is
Exhibit A allowing Lehman to go down and
all the bad things that followed is is
not something to be proud of there are a
number of times when they've moved
slowly to understand what why monetary
policy was not having the effect they
hoped and but again and again what what
chairman Bernanke's showed is
willingness to to to look at the world
as it is to understand what what isn't
working and why and to use everything
within his power both as a persuader as
a communist as a thinker to find answers
to try and get our the US economy into a
better be okay so let's call let's turn
to Jean Claude trichet who was headed
the European Central Bank during the
crisis how is he different from Bernanke
what do you think of him he's a he's a
he's a different animal he's a Frenchman
who was born in 1942 he's a lifelong
public servant he went to the French
essentially the French finishing school
for 44 bureaucrats worked in the French
Treasury made his way to the bunk de
France the French central bank and
really was you know a real up-and-comer
in the in the 1970s and 80s in the in
the French civil service before becoming
central banker where he helped manage
for France this transition to the euro
so his entire life has been about
creating a united Europe creating
instead of you have France and Germany
and Italy and Spain you have a united
Europe that has its own currency has
deep ties between nations that's his
life's project he he became president of
the european central bank in 2003 you
know he is many ways a veteran crisis
fighter he was a veteran of these these
battles it was called the Paris Club
working out debt in Latin American
government debt in Latin American other
emerging market countries in the late
80s Early 90s he's a crisis fighter it's
in his bones he's a negotiator he's a
arm twister he can get a deal done when
it needs to be done a less experienced
not much of an economist he's you know
Ben Bernanke or mervyn king or much you
know bigger economic thinkers but rachet
is a he's a skillful maneuver and
operator in a in a government or central
bank kind of setting now Bernanke really
opened the spigots of money in the you
I mean he cut interest rates
aggressively at the beginning and then
they've bought trillions of dollars of
bonds the European Central Bank has been
less aggressive is that because the
circumstances are different or you think
that's just a different view between
Tricia and Bernanke it's more than the
individuals it goes much deeper in the
organization's the ECB part of its
entire framework and thesis under which
was created it's only been around since
1998 and the the theory as is you have
these European countries that do not
have a strong tradition of stable money
of low inflation you have countries like
france and italy and spain as part of
this currency zone and germany which has
very much a tradition at least since the
since the 20s of stable money and low
inflation there was a desire to bring
some of the credibility of the Buddha's
bank the german central bank to all of
europe and so a lot of the the ways the
ECB is set up it's even in frankfurt
where the blue news bank also is they
have a single mandate to maintain low
and stable inflation a bit under two
percent they you know a lot of the
difference with the Fed is that the Fed
has anna mandate to worry both about
unemployment in the flesh exactly the
Fed now does aim for two percent
inflation but they also aim to keep
unemployment low you know it's it's kind
of in the water in the ECB that that
even though there's people of all
nationalities working there it's the
kind of German approach that we as the
central bank need to focus on stable
prices everything else will take care of
itself it's sort of a bizarre when you
look back on it that Tricia actually
raised interest rates during the crisis
well that'll add a couple of junctures
that that seem like mistakes in
hindsight summer 2008 when which was
right before Lehman went under and and
the entire world collapsed and then
again in the spring and summer of 2011
which was just as we entered a darker
phase the European crisis and and the
risk of Europe falling apart your did
fall into recession and and you know we
came to to the very brink of some very
nasty things in Europe so what kind of
great do you think he'll get from
history he gets a
you know he gets a low be you know he he
was unable to do something that mario
draghi his successor has been able to do
i take that back i'll bring trish a down
to a see because on the one hand trichet
was able to corral this ECB to do some
things that were very uncomfortable for
that organization starting in May 2010
the ECB went into bond markets to try
and relieve the pressure on grease on
Portugal Ireland to to help use their
bottomless ability to print euros just
to try and steer that Europe away from
the abyss it succeeded to a degree but
the problem is it was haphazard it was
not part of an overarching plan and then
as European leaders trichet was not able
to corral and steer European leaders to
take their steps so that there was a
simultaneous political unity arriving
along with monetary support for that
unity right his successor has been far
more effective at that so a successor
Mario Draghi and Italian who has been
Italian central banker how how do you
think he's handled things differently
than tree today a couple of things he's
been willing to so it's been a
diplomatic touches a key to
understanding why Mario Draghi has had
success in really barely a year a year
and a half in in office he started in
november two thousand eleven what Mario
Draghi has been able to his first deal
with the acute crisis he inherited when
he starred in 2011 he cut interest rates
to deal with the recession and try and
reduce the the economic downturn in
Europe he started what ended up being
about a trillion euro backstop to the
banking system called the LTR a
long-term refinancing operation and said
all right the first thing we're going to
do is flood money to the banking system
to keep this this crisis from spreading
and pain from country to country and
then he set to work as things got you
know rough again in the summer 2012 he
said all right forget these kind of
half-baked you no half measures to
inject money into the European bond
markets we're going to do whatever it
takes those were his words in a speech
in London last July we the ECB will do
whatever it takes to to ensure there's a
fiscal backstop to keep to keep Europe
from collapsing and and he then managed
the diplomacy to make that happen he has
support within the German
government though not the Bundesbank he
he's he's played his cards in a very
careful way that look the future for
Europe is still being written I we still
don't know how exactly you're F will
look a few years from now but it's a
much better shape than it was it so
deeply doesn't love Mario Draghi is more
like Bernanke than Trichet was I Mario
Draghi is a more skillful politician
than Bernanke I would argue what he has
in common with Bernanke is a willingness
to look at the world as it is look at
the economics and and try and push his
committee push his organization toward
what needs to be done based on the
economic fundamentals and not be
restrained as much by a sense of
morality on what ought to be done or a
sense of constraints driven by by by the
tradition of that organization hmm okay
and Mervyn King it's a smaller economy
the UK but one that has a lot of
prominence and of course as you point
out in the book a lot of history and
central banking modern central banking
largely was invented by the by the
British what's he like and how well did
he think he handled the crisis Marvin
Kings an interesting character I think
he's as you say it's it's the smallest
economy of the three it's it has an
outsized importance because of the large
financial sector in London but you know
Mervyn King is a fascinating character
he's I'm told a wonderful person talked
to he's a you know a charmer he throws
nice dinners at his club he you know
enjoy sports she enjoys socializing with
with intellectuals and artists he he
manages to clash with almost everyone he
seems with whether to the Bank of
England or in British politics he has
very sharp elbows in internal politics
he's very self-confident he he he knows
what his views are he thinks he's right
it takes a great deal to persuade him
that he's wrong he thinks that his view
of how the world should work which is
crisp and academic and theoretical he
thinks that's the model of how you ought
to make decisions I here are two reasons
I don't think history will judge Mervyn
King's tenure at the Bank of England
terribly well you know he very much was
part of a shift away from the business
of financial stability at the bank of
england in the years before the crisis
you know this was a time in which the
the british banking sector became
huge multiple of British GDP and size
and you know essentially bank regulation
it kind of been shunted off to a
different regulator to the FSA the Bank
of England I'm told over and over by
people who have been inside that worked
inside the bank during this time that it
was kind of a career graveyard to go
into bank regulation of supervision but
turns out all those things about how the
banking system was work was working or
not working we're very important to the
economy and financial stability that's
one reason I think urban kings track
record does not look great the other is
that he very much was an advocate of
Britain taking a turn toward fiscal
austerity in 2010 he was vocal and out
there telling the politicians in ways
that really come against the borders of
what six what's you know influencing
politics too much saying we need to cut
our deficit right now if we don't very
bad things could happen we've now seen
three years since then of four years
almost of stagnant growth in Britain and
that fiscal austerity that he advocated
as part of the reason hmm so his great
it's cliche to see he's a he's a c-minus
and now some of this it seems to me has
to do with outcomes that people feel
better about Bernanke although he still
has obviously unpopular in many quarters
in the United States because the US
economy has done okay we're not in
recession any longer the British economy
as you point out is in the tank and
Europe is not doing that well how much
do you think these guys get more blame
or credit than they deserve so it's
important to remember a central banker
his tools are limited central banker
can't control everything that goes on in
the economy really I read that and so
you know writers like us we it's very
important what they do and they they
really do shape the course of economies
and end of the world that said at the
end of the day they they do have finite
powers they can use they when you when
you really boil it down they have a dial
right they can say we're going to put
more money into the economy or less now
it's a lot more complicated than that as
as as you and I know they have they can
regulate banks they can try and
influence things in other ways but but
to think that everything that has gone
wrong is is their fault is wrong
think that everything that has gone
right is is you know the Alan Greenspan
probably got too much credit for the
Great Moderation for the many years of
strong growth we had in the 2000s you
know it's it's easy to to blame Alan
Greenspan and the Federal Reserve before
the crisis for what we see now is
probably overstating things as well so
both of us have read an admired Lee acha
acha meds book the lords of finance
which is about these guys predecessor in
the 20s where we know how the story
ended it ended miserably when you look
at that book and you look at the
interaction between Bernanke Mervyn King
and Mario and don't collect rachet how
is it different than it was in the 20s I
think that's the that's the overarching
story that I'm that I'm trying to tell
here which is that whereas 70 80 years
ago the global central bankers that they
were divided by a lot of things they
were divided by nationalistic mistrust
they didn't trust each other they were
divided by not having a common
understanding of how the economy works
and what their role ought to be is
central bankers they were they were
blinded by a devotion that lasted longer
than should have to the gold standard in
trying to keep their currencies pegged
gold all those things enabled the what
started as a pretty routine stock market
decline in the United States in 1929 and
and ripples two different German and
European banks and the in 1930 that
turned into the Great Depression that
led to double-digit unemployment in most
of the Western world that led to World
War two and that was a time when lack of
coordination lack of a sense of common
resolve among the central bankers had
devastating results we have we've
experienced the opposite this time
around these are guys who have a deep
mutual respect for each other they they
meet you know six times a year in Basel
Switzerland they
go to the bank of Bank for International
Settlements it's a big cylindrical
building right near the bottle train
station and most of their time there
it's almost a respite they go and they
talk about big economic ideas and the
central bankers from across the earth
come in and they talk about what they're
seeing in their countries and trying to
bait and understand how the world is
evolving in the evenings they go and
have a very nice dinner and the top
floor of this building and it's
overlooking switzerland and germany and
france and we have a great wine cellar
excellent wine cellar they call it
ground crew bis they drink good wine
they eat good food it's an intimate
gathering things do not leak out of that
dinner unfortunately unfortunately we
despite that their publication is trying
to try to learn what we can so you know
I mean that's it the the meetings and
the wine are little things but there's a
sense of common purpose in a sense that
they are in this together we saw that
again and again in this crisis you know
you and I both know about the swap lines
which they did first in on large scale
in fall 2008 but they came back to it
I'd say what those are the web so bored
what was happening is European banks had
lots of obligations in dollars but the
European Central Bank the ECB can't give
them dollars recife only has euros and
so this was this was a big problem and
this could have caused the the world
financial system to come unglued the
Federal Reserve said to the ECB okay
well let's do this I'll give you dollars
you give me a similar amount of euros
you can then lend those dollars to your
banks in Europe and on your own terms
and however you think is best when the
you know when we hit the 90 days
whatever the time is we we swap back and
no harm no foul no doesn't cost anybody
any money but doing that the ECB pays
the that's right there's interest rate
yes sorry and so you know it's a it's a
way that the we essentially the Federal
Reserve became lender of last resort to
the world making dollars available not
just the ECB the Bank of England the
Swedish central bank the swiss national
bank and you know that's that's partly a
reflection of the sense of common
purpose of these central bankers shared
right as you point out in the book it's
not only that way it's that when the Fed
was lending money to banks when they
expanded their lending to
blending through banks through the
discount window and it's and it's the
thing that evolved into this auction
facility it turns out we now know a lot
of European banks were borrowing direct
from the fed through their us offices so
it strikes me is exactly as you say
exactly the opposite of the 20s when
each of them was pulling apart and this
time they're much more pushing pulling
together and that's something I think
I'll be honest even I as a beat reporter
covering the Fed did not fully
understand at the time you know they
announced this new lending facility and
I kind of got my head around this was
person else in December of 2007 which
seems like an eternity ago more than
five years ago you know we now know
because all this information has come
out through FOIA requests and lawsuits
and and the dodd-frank act that
overwhelmingly that money ended up being
hundreds and hundreds of billions of
dollars was being went to European banks
that had us offices not to the banks
that you use and this was you know this
would have been politically explosive if
this was widely understood